welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the new
trailer for doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness now this is a
teaser that rolled after the credits of
spider-man no way home but with some
titles added new details there and while
i did begin to break down this footage
in our post credit scene video now that
this trailer is online i need to go
through this frame by frame to break
down the new details that we can now see
specifically i am now obsessed with
everyone's hands also everyone's hands
in this trailer oh and speaking of
strange be sure to get our new limited
edition strange entanglement shirt at
newarkstarsmerch.com i'd love that no
way home design here we go don't guess
that spell
it's too dangerous why we tampered with
the stability of space time
the multiverse
is a concept about which we know
frighteningly little
okay we open with the audio from
spider-man no way home including
strange's lectures to peter parker and
acting sorcerer supreme wong's warning
to strange strange don't cast that spell
it's too dangerous which interestingly
was in the no way home trailer but not
in the movie itself that just had wong
saying leave me out of this we could be
seeing one reality in which wong did
actually warn strange because we're
gonna be seeing lots of different
realities in this movie candles blow out
at kamar taj probably the same shot
where an ominous cloud looms over it and
we see strange's broken watch from the
2016 film which symbolized his own
broken hands and the way he broke time
to defeat dormammu which is one of the
many reality meddling choices that he
made throughout the mcu to desecrate the
multiverse like this and now that bill
has come due moving on
it was the only way so we hear the voice
of mordo still on that anti-sorcerer
crusade from the 2016 film and strange
looks out to see the city block
disintegrating looking a lot like the
visuals from what if episode 4 when
doctor strange bypassed an absolute
point and began to melt reality into
dark matter by far my favorite episode
of that series and one that seems like
it'll have real implications on this
film also notice here that strange's
cloak looks torn it is missing a chunk
from the back so this is on the other
side of some scuffle he got into doctor
strange has the eye of agamotto necklace
once more as he did in no way home
despite thanos breaking it infinity war
and the time stone that it wants house
being atomized but oda says strange now
wears it way higher on his chest closer
to his neck as opposed to dangling lower
on his chest so the eye of agamotto
still must have some additional magic to
it and strange needs that magic close to
his head maybe this also helps the cloak
protect it moving on
but i never
meant for any of this to happen
[Music]
okay the sanctum lobby is now flooded
with sea water from a beach on the other
side of that broken wall now in no way
home they had left the rotunda gateway
open to siberia causing that blizzard to
freeze it over but we also got one
cryptic line about the sanctum walls
being built at the intersection of
cosmic energy currents so nature
spilling into the sanctum in both of
these cases could actually be a
reflection of the multiverse coming
apart and we see shots of wanda's red
chaos magic and christine palmer's
wedding day where strange watches from
the pews alongside dr nick west notice
how strange tucks a bit of red into his
front pocket maybe his cloak in case he
needs a quick change then in the star
jacket is america chavez the young
multiversal warrior who comes from the
utopian parallel she's played by zochi
gomez known for kick and star portals
and we may actually see one of those
star portals here you can see a giant
blue star as a sorcerer tumbled through
it at first i thought it was strange
from that gray stripe but this person
has a ponytail so maybe this is another
sorcerer or america or one of america's
parents the moment she loses them the
marvel studios logo is filtered through
broken glass to show different comic
book backgrounds in the letters we are
expected to see a ton of cameos of
alternate universe avengers in this
movie there are rumors of hayley atwell
returning as captain carter in live
action maybe even deadpool in this movie
and notice how the marvel logos include
ones used in past mcu phases and ones
used ahead of marvel films by other
studios like the fox x-men films we are
all praying juana maximum pulls the
reverse house of m to declare let there
be mutants and maybe bring x-men into
the mcu but hopefully no boner this time
boner
moving on
one day
i knew sooner or later you'd show up
i made mistakes
and people were hurt i'm not here to
talk about westview then what are you
here for
i need your help
guess what
what do you know about the multiverse
okay strange visits with wanda maximoff
apparently having relocated from her
remote mountain cabin and the vision
post-credits scene to this serene
orchard estate with sheep this time
animal sheep who must follow her like
sheep instead of humans
but we still have to wonder if this
could actually be another pocket reality
of wanda's design with its neatly
groomed orchard that wanda can be alone
and away from everyone in as she
continues to search in the dark hold for
her children it was actually confirmed
by marvel studios that doctor strange
did know what wanda was doing in west
view and that those commercials were
actually intended to be messages from dr
strange including the final one
confirming that wanda maximoff was a
nexus being and including that cryptic
line of ask your doctor but that cameo
was removed from one division because
they didn't want to make it too much
about doctor strange want to keep it
focused on wanda i know i know spiderman
no way home just gave us the perfect
holiday gift and i think we need a way
to celebrate the magnitude of this
occasion well our merch partners at epic
hero are stepping up to release the
biggest shirts of the year not like in
size but you know in like they're a big
deal i'm very important my apartment
smells of rich mahogany they have
multiple new shirt designs inspired by
no way home strange entanglement is the
newest member of their limited edition
latest obsession line it looks so cool
they also have a new spider polo the
spiritual successor to their mega hit
loki gator polo it's a perfect gift for
the nerd who likes to break up the
t-shirt rotation with an occasional
collared shirt you know it gives it
gives some structure to this undefined
unknown region but there's also a sick
sinister six shirt in the style of the
usual suspects movie poster and of
course way more spidey merch on the way
really they have all kinds of shirts and
hoodies and stickers other merch
inspired by loki shengchi other
properties including a new kingpin
inspired shirt long live the king
celebrating wilson fisk's return to the
mcu in hawkeye and of course there's
also official new rockstars merch with
our logo some cases with my name if you
ever see me in public and you're wearing
one of these i am legally required to
high-five you so what you gotta do is
sign up for their newsletter at the
bottom of their website to get notified
about the latest merch drops and check
out all of their incredible products at
epicheroshop.com be your own hero let's
move on
[Music]
i'm sorry steven
i hope you understand
so here doctor strange america chavez
and christine palmer enter through this
hatch of a ship a sign on the left read
keep door closed and on the other side
it opens to a new dimension with broken
columns and a central statue that emits
a light source i wonder if this could be
the ruins of america's home reality the
utopian parallel interesting to include
christine palmer on that journey though
and then mordo confronts strange with
his awesome new look then we see the
scarlet witch in a seance wearing her
new outfit that she gained in wanovision
by defeating nag of the hardness but new
detail i love notice wanda's fingertips
they are fading black the way agathas
would when she cast a spell it's a very
cool way of showing how wanda is using
that same dark magic that agatha used
that drains some of your own life force
moving on the greatest threat
to our universe
so mordo and strange duel calling back
their sparring in the 2016 film strange
string something between his wrists to
block the blow from mordo then we see
this explosion in the kamataj courtyard
and if you look closely in the middle
there is a horned minotaur minotaur-like
beast stand in the center between this
and gargantos by the way that's not
shumagurath this movie is gonna be
filled with supernatural monsters and
entities then strange conjures some red
chaos magic like that of wanda and
projecting these various orbs that i've
suspected could depict the multiverse
and how those various worlds are now
tethered together notice how this
location has that harp from the layer of
dark strange but notice that broken
sanctum window in the background earlier
we saw some strange's hand over a
similarly lit window with dust
collecting on the sill so this frame may
have been broken enraged by that variant
of strange it may have caused what is
happening to his hand then there's a
quick shot of the sanctum tea room with
america and wong where strange releases
these serpentine forms from his hands
this looks just like strange's various
attacks in that what if episode after he
absorbed various interdimensional beings
i really do think the meddling of
strange supreme in that episode is gonna
be a huge reason why the multiverse in
this film is collapsing the way it is
then gargantos throws the buses strange
with that cafe layaway ad unlock a
better day interesting choice of words
for a film with doors throughout the
production design and speaking of which
that phone booth to the left has an ad
reading the magic of tea this phone
booth could be another portal and exit
point for these characters and on to the
final clip
is you
things just got out of hand
[Music]
so strange faces his dark variant in
this variant's sanctum and while i think
strange supreme could be brought into
this movie he was not exactly this
flavor of dark i think this is yet
another variant and while he does have
both his hands and every other shot in
this last one his left hand is kind of
hard to see i wanna know where that hand
went because we know strange is all
about his hands hands that like to grope
him when he goes through the multiverse
i also mentioned how strange has a bit
of purple reflected in his eye which
could just be the lighting but since he
is delving into wanda's red chaos magic
also mixed up with all that is all the
purple dark magic that she absorbed from
agatha so i'm gonna be talking about
this film a lot more in the new year but
after we break down the hawkeye finale
next week we're gonna take a little
break from marvel content to enjoy our
holidays and then we're gonna return
first week in january to hit everything
hard anytime you can support us and get
yourself some great christmas gift
options by checking out that strange
entanglement shirt at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter ea boss follow new
rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything marvel
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you